[Musik]
van der horst vor future heute mit
kritiker cdu elisabeth kaiser spd luise
amtsberg die grüne und quantas von
friday the future herzlich willkommen zu
van der horst for future frau kaiser
zukunft ist das eine kategorie in der
man als sozialdemokrat noch denkt schon
damals gerade erst ein parteitag gehabt
mit dem titel genannt wurde in die neue
zeit also das spielt schon seit vier
zukunft mit was ist denn ihre konkrete
forderung an kritiker er sitzt jetzt
hier
wir können ja auch noch mal nicht können
sie müssen knallhart jetzt fordere gut
ich da die forderung dass wir hier heute
beschließen wir beide gehören die grd
mittel damit wir was für mich die grw
mittel dafür nun die grw mission
gemeinschaftsaufgabe regionale
wirtschaftsförderung verhandelt so die
gruppe jeden tag also ich hoffe nicht
wenn ihre partei ein tier wäre welches
tier wäre sie und warum meine partei
wäre eine eule bei eine sehr weise ist
und also sie steht für weisheit sagt es
so und eule schläft natürlich auch
wahnsinnig viel wenn ich andere tiere
aber sieht sehr schläfrig aus zumindest
alter schläfriger vogel aber sie hat
ohne halt nicht sein name stützt da sie
direkt viel sympathie für viele menschen
zusammen zu bauen
gut ich würde sagen denn wahl sind laut
gross wir seien vom aussterben bedroht
und haben viel haben viel plastik auch
in uns drin und deswegen ist glaube ich
einmal eine gute lösung vor amsberg ich
würde sagen sehr und weil schnell
präzise aber er trägt pelz ist das okay
es ist ein eigener fans das ist schon
gut gelaufen
[Musik]
er sehe jetzt schön wenn wir jetzt alle
ein zeichen setzen für co2 einsparung
deswegen schlage ich vor dass wir jetzt
alle mal die luft anhalten fürs klima
und wir schauen wer es am längsten
schafft mit nase zuhalten sehr gut mit
nase zuhalten es kein leben mein ring
sie können sich die nase zu holen 123
die spd es auch raus im rennen noch frei
der future gegen die cdu 25 durch in der
region
ich habe erst mal und sie kommen sogar
hass befragt aber auch hier schlagen das
verbot war schon das streamen von online
pornos produziert so viel co2 wie ganz
belgien
aber was könnten sie eher verzichten auf
online pornos oder auf belgien benutze
ich dass eine nochmalig in dem anderen
wir sind beides männer harris war
eigentlich sexistisch wenn ich mir
darüber nachdenke
sie findet dass sexistische ja ich meine
auch frauen pornos frau kaiser ich
konnte mir keiner ab na gut dann fragen
wir mal welche männer konsumieren denn
hier online
ich wäre es wäre gelogen wenn ich nie
getan hätte dem würde ich mich
anschließen
aber man hat auch eine kooperation für
freundlich der future gehabt die haben
sie sich vor nur industrie hat auch zu
globalen klima streiks hierbei seiten
runter genommen und die haben auch
werbefilme gedreht
und zum abschied sehen wir noch alle ein
ökologisches weihnachtslied nämlich und
anbauen 123 tannenbaum oh tannenbaum mit
diesem wunderschönen verlogen sondern
geht nicht zurück
michael b schreibt auf facebook wilke du
bist der letzte arsch nur große fresse
ich möchte ich mal sehen wenn es hart
auf hart kommt dann schaust du dir in
die hose warte ab ein sprichwort sagt
man trifft sich immer zweimal im leben
mach weiter so mit einer großen fresse
wie können warten
sehr geehrter herr b man sieht sich im
leben nicht nur zweimal sondern jeden
freitag um 22.30 in zweiter oder hier
auf youtube wenn sie uns abonnieren